[Musique]
le fac de damocalyptody Alpes
ont fait mentir les sondages aux
élections américaines de mi-mandat mardi
dernier des républicains devraient
contrôler la Chambre des Représentants
une fois que tous les votes auront été
comptabilisés mais la vague rouge que
plusieurs prédisaient ne s'est pas
matérialisé qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
bien je me tourne vers mon ami Alex
Panetta Washington correspondant de la
CBC qui était avec nous la semaine
dernière vous voyez pas faire de
prédiction la semaine dernière vous êtes
un homme prudent vous qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé je t'ai dit Daniel que je
suis sorti de cette business là de faire
des prédictions avec raison parce que
tout le monde est étonné par ce résultat
même la plupart des démocrates c'est du
jamais vu normalement le parti au
pouvoir pair en moyenne 27 sièges dans
la chambre et aujourd'hui même avec
l'inflation même avec un président
populaire même avec un public
historiquement et satisfait avec la
direction du pays qui ont perdu
quasiment zéro on compte toujours les
votes et c'est pas totalement exclu
comme tu as dit c'est peu probable pas
impossible que démocrate remporte les
deux chambres cette hallucinant alors ta
question pourquoi mais la raison numéro
1 c'est l'avortement on l'a vu cette
année dans les élections partielles et
démocrates soudainement commençaient à
gagner des partiels après une année
misérable pour eux aux urnes en 2021
soudainement le taux de participation
des jeunes des femmes augmentent
qu'est-ce que bon alors intéressant
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire maintenant
pour la seconde moitié de la présidence
de Biden le qui était vu comme comme
étant parti pour être un peu du côté
faible mais là les choses sont les
perspectives sont améliorées c'était
drôle de voir le président le lendemain
l'élection normalement il y a une
tradition rituelle le jour après un
mi-mandat sur le président se présente
au micro à la Maison Blanche et à la
face longue il a perdu 25-40 63 sièges
dans le code Bill Clinton il déclare
solennellement d'avoir compris le
message d'une population population
amère et il promet de
de faire mieux mais quand on a posé la
question à Biden l'autre jour que
changeras-tu il a répondu rien je ne
change rien j'ai jamais vu ça de ma
fille mais la situation est plus
complexe que cela et pas nécessairement
facile pour lui alors si on présume que
les républicains et apprennent contrôle
dans la chambre et que les démocrates
gardent le Sénat ça veut dire que sinon
Biden Perk continuer de nommer ses juges
et de les faire confirmer par son parti
au Sénat cela veut dire qu'il peut
continuer de réformer un système
judiciaire qui depuis quelques années on
constate que sa penché vers la droite
mais clairement il y a du négatif pour
lui aussi si les républicains gagnent la
chambre ceux qui sont probables pas
certain ça veut dire que ces projets
doit sont bloqués ça risque d'avoir même
un effet mondial des projets de loi pour
financer l'Ukraine par exemple je crois
que ça va probablement continuer mais
désormais c'est pas garanti ça sera plus
difficile on pourrait aussi voir une
crise américaine à les républicains
menaces de bloquer des budgets comme
tactique de négociation avec Biden et
finalement au point de vue personnel ça
sera pénible pour enquêter son fils ses
entreprises de famille alors ça sera pas
deux années faciles pour lui non plus
bon la semaine dernière on parlait des
candidats qui réfutaient à la victoire
de byden lors de la dernière élection
quantique ont-ils bien performé oh non
c'était une soirée misérable pour les
complotistes que j'ai compté 6 états
clés ou ce genre de monde présentait
pour administrer les élections ça aurait
pu avoir un effet sur l'élection de 2024
et sur ces 6 je compte aujourd'hui qu'il
y a zéro peut-être un qui gagnera ses
élections en mauvaise soirée pour les
complotistes une bonne soirée peut-être
pour la stabilité de la démocratie
américaine bon maintenant quel est
l'impact de ce résultat là sur
l'influence de Donald Trump au sein du
parti républicain monsieur Trump la
chantant qui l'annoncera son retour en
politique mardi prochain alors qu'il
sera lancera dans la course à la
présidence et quand il il sera
facilement le favori sur le côté
républicain mais sans plus vulnérable
qu'auparavant assez candidats les
complotistes qu'il a promis ont eu une
soirée difficile d'autres républicains
plus traditionnels disons ont gagné
facilement dans les mêmes États en
Géorgie par exemple alors les gens de
citron pour un nouveau argument qu'on
lui pour dire c'est un loser il a perdu
en 2018 le Congrès il a perdu l'élection
2020 au Sénat dans la chambre et en 2022
il nous a fait mal encore bon ce serait
intéressant surveillant ouvert
commençons par voir s'il y a un autre sa
candidature ce qui semble tout semble
nous laisser croire que c'est vers ça
qui s'en va puis on va sûrement vous
réinviter pour en parler à l'exponiteur
Washington merci beaucoup merci